that is foolish man check me out on the
bootleg kel podcast let's get it
yo bullet cat podcast special guest in
here my guy
yo julio welcome back sir
how you feeling i'm feeling good man i
saw using uh well my engineer ran into
at the 7-eleven
i'm out of taping i'm like yo pull back
up on the show man i saw your uh
you were in l.a in the hoovers today
uh oh yes is that yesterday
yo that was i went that they had put up
to my videos too oh that was okay it was
in the middle unless someone went for
this [ __ ] locker fence you were doing a
shoot in the middle of their hood though
oh they go to bed but they pulled up
quick so i don't think it was too far so
sure
do you know they have a lot of uh la
sets that are everywhere um
is there any la gang sets that are in
jacksonville
i don't know it's a couple plus a couple
clubs but anything big though like how
it is out here
all right [ __ ]
yeah the hoovers are there's some
serious guys shout out to all the homies
uh
what has been going on with you though
man i feel like i i've been happy to see
that i i feel like for the most part
you've been kind of out the way as far
as like seeing some i haven't seen no
crazy [ __ ] going on involving your name
mm-hmm
i really like chilling like get about
getting everything together because i
really think about dropping like a album
but i'll probably go put out like two
tapes before that but i just been
chilling trying to pull out like more
like relatable music like more like
melodic type [ __ ] like that's what i'm
really on right now
trying to stay away from the um
i mean you know people kind of know you
for the op [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
are you kind of trying to are you off
that right now kind of disorder that's
all in my life without what i live but
yeah kind of sword i've been chilling
i feel like the last conversation we had
you were very like uh
you know it kind of surprised me how
mature you were and kind of where your
head was involving a lot of that type of
energy you know it kind of felt like you
were over it as well exactly yeah
do you feel like um at like like
mentally you're in the best place you've
been in so far since you've been you
know kind of nationally known
uh
i wouldn't say that but i feel like i'm
like more like
on track
because i know like i got a goal i got
people to feed i got a family to feed so
i can't just be doing dumb [ __ ] mm-hmm
exactly how many kids you got oh my god
no kids no kids no i don't know i don't
got no kids shout out to you
i got two yeah i got no kids at all not
ready for the children yet
um i ordered a jet but i do the way i
got to be the right child because these
females be bogus super bogus focuses
yeah
yeah uh
did you see the chris brown that you
know they they uh just
um accused chris brown a rape
and then
the girl after the accusations like she
like tried to go to the police and sue
him yeah was in his dm sending him voice
notes saying he was the best dick she
ever had so they dropped the charges
it's like these [ __ ] are crazy
exactly that's why you gotta watch who
like
you mingle with cause like these females
they have bad intentions when you famous
and got status and [ __ ]
so they'll play you to the left just to
get some money or just to put you until
i throw dirt on your name man
now i'm gonna keep it 9.7 out of 10 like
[ __ ] don't be rapping these females
bro that just be like could come up for
them like i if i see self i'm out of
public right and i get into altercation
with a fan like they just do that to get
like the baby for example how he get all
these lawsuits and [ __ ] it just happened
to emily choppa in the airport
some random fan ran up on him and
dudes but you know it's like
that'd be like the clout
yeah well you got to watch how you move
that just be cover-ups i know what i see
that they were trying to come up
yeah i think um unfortunately it kind of
comes with the territory when you're
when you're in the position you're in
it's like
especially with females like you said
like
you might you don't even gotta mess with
the chick you don't even gotta kiss the
girl you don't gotta be romantically
interested but if he was in the same
role
room vicinity party
and you're the only famous person there
like you never know how that can come
out you know what i mean exactly it's
just like yeah i think that that's just
that's what's kind of unfortunate about
today's times man is like a lot of
people are looking for that short nut as
opposed to earning their [ __ ] the right
way you know what are you telling [ __ ]
[ __ ] up [ __ ] is [ __ ] up man yeah the
babies i feel like the babies probably
more people test the baby than anybody
and and he keeps winning those 10 he
keeps passing those tests with flying
clubs i don't know why they keep playing
[ __ ] i'm like this guy murdered well he
didn't murder someone he was defending
himself in a walmart yeah and he killed
somebody in front of his daughter who's
trying to come at him
that's what i went through that's real i
was defending myself you know
you know what i'm saying at the end of
the day we got to protect our brains so
you can't just
certain people ain't going out the same
way like you can't just walk up on
certain artists because certain artists
really come from the streets and you
know what i'm saying they got a lot of
[ __ ] at home they gotta make it back to
kids family mom dad
yeah so yeah that so some something
similar that happened to the baby
happened to you
yeah well
what was the circumstance i was um
finishing my last mistake love me like
i'm dead last call
i was at like a public studio in
jacksonville and as i was walking out of
studio
my car i got shot at along my car like
getting this out of my car and i shot
back and sell the fence like you know
i'm saying that [ __ ] was just another
wild ass situation that's it was all
over the noodles everywhere did uh
anything did you end up hitting anybody
um i made them drop they clip though and
i got grades to like the ankle though
some [ __ ] i did see you got shot or
grazed i guess that's right great thank
you
yeah um
it's that's that's that's kind of
in your hometown yeah obviously
jacksonville probably for use hotter
than any other city in terms of just
people
not wanting to see you you know
do your thing um
did you come out of that situation like
what because when you're that close to
you know that bullets a foot up a foot
to the right or you know
that dude's aims a little bit better
yeah it could be all bad for you did
that [ __ ] like um
kind of like
do anything to you as far as just
changing your mentality or or changing
the way you think the way you move
really i wasn't even supposed to be at
that studio i got too comfortable and i
knew in my head i went for the beard
that studio just recording but i was
just
trying to finish my mistake from my fans
and get it turned in and get a little um
just to let them hear what i'm like my
new sound you know what i'm saying but i
wasn't supposed to be at that studio in
jasmine that was really all on me like
you kind of knew you weren't supposed to
be there yeah you're like you know what
i left myself i was i was i was sitting
here and yeah
100
yeah i i do see that happening a lot
like you know i think sometimes
when you're from a certain area you you
that's where you're going to let your
guard down most of the time and that's
probably where you shouldn't you know
that's what happened obviously dolph was
at home in memphis when he when he got
when he got got and uh
that's crazy man damn
so um
you
the cops come
question you
thank god it happened in florida because
most states
so at least in florida there's like the
stand your ground law and you know you
could be like yeah i was defending
myself so
yeah so that was the end of that
yeah i had um
after that situation they had took my
gun i'm gonna get my guns back though
but they had to my gun ran ballistics
and [ __ ] to make sure i would tell them
the truth
yeah man we're good for you bro mm-hmm
did you have any idea who did it
obviously don't tell us but did you have
any any idea i was at a public studio so
immediately
yeah that was what i'm saying a million
people come to the studio in a session
before me sets it after me so someone
hop on the phone y'all who knows in the
studio get what i'm saying they could be
the female or anybody so i was just like
in the midst of some [ __ ] i went for to
be are you like making it a point to try
to stay away from jacksonville because i
i just don't know what what good can
come from you going home the cops ain't
[ __ ] with you there
you got your family your friends i'm
sure the people who matter closest to
you are probably with you where you're
at now
like is there a reason to go back home
besides maybe getting a bag or
you know i i don't know i just beat up
like truthfully for my brothers
sometimes i just be hanging out with my
brothers and [ __ ] yeah everybody my
family really don't stay there
my main family i would say you took your
family out of there right yeah so i just
really beat up for my brothers trying to
get [ __ ] in line so we called just you
know what i'm saying movies wanna get
[ __ ] together and [ __ ] is there a
certain point
where you hit a certain level of stardom
or success where you
kind of say to yourself well listen to
the homies like hey y'all know
it's love but i can't be in the same
place as y'all be at anymore because
it's just
you know counter counter
intuitive to what i'm trying to do
or is that something you're always going
to go back to no
not really because i've still been in
the same places i just
i know certain places i can't be in
jasper though like i ain't going to go
downtown like by the police where the
police like that's dumb i'll just be in
my certain areas why not downtown
because that's where the police like
really be real hot hot like oh so the
cops out there like it's like they are
they record they know they're hot
everywhere but downtown they're like
mainly where they be stationed
so yeah it is how you move
the super bowl has the super bowl been
to jacksonville since you i mean since
you've been like prominent as far as an
artist
i know it's been there before
that's kind of what i was little but
it's gonna be a wild time the next time
the super bowl comes through
jacksonville that's gonna be lit
okay when it was in tampa it was live
for like they put on for the whole
florida what was crazy about the tampa
[ __ ] is it was like the the pandemic
super bowl and they did it in florida
so [ __ ] wasn't closed everything was up
lit were you in tampa yeah i was in tupa
tampa's a wild place too yeah i lived in
tampa a few years
they get a temper and temple like a good
i feel like it's going to be the new
life
when people go to florida they just
think about miami tampa from the be the
new like it state you know i've been
saying that for a long time i think too
just like even like in terms of like the
florida cities music scene i feel like
they're next to kind of have
a wave because i feel like every other
part of florida for the most part is
kind of caught on
and um
obviously like there's some dope artists
out of tampa taliban duda and
tom g and go on and on there's some fire
artists out of florida uh richie west
young dredd um but i feel like they
haven't had their time yet i feel like
orlando
jacksonville everyone's had you know has
their time but i feel like tampa's up
next for sure exactly and and tampa is a
[ __ ] vibe it was warm
on the east coast of florida boy you got
to think about they got the beaches they
got this casino they got everything you
want though it's a good market for
investing in properties like it just lit
bro there's a lot of money down there
are you uh are you invested in
properties at all i want to get into it
though i just gotta like mingle with the
right people but i'm gonna get into
before this year over with yeah i think
it's a good idea man because uh well the
other thing is i mean look you got the
jewelry right now watches
are uh
rolex's specifically yeah
a lot of people are saying that they're
like great investments at the moment
i was just talking to a jeweler about
that today at the gym
heart like a lot of hard assets during
the pandemic is like shot up so you [ __ ]
whatever if you got a rolly or something
like that that should probably really i
got two rollies but i gave one of my
luck
i don't know if it uh if it hurts the
value that it's uh that is iced out
though i'm gonna be honest yeah i know
they like playing james i think yeah
which is kind of crazy to think about
yeah i heard that too though
would you
would you would you rock a plane jane
like more modest i mean obviously you
got a lot of [ __ ] jewelry on but it
depends
i don't like it but investment
standpoint i might just get one ain't no
chatting with me the bus did not get
what i like you know what i'm saying
this is a new chain right here of your
boy oh the baby's saying yeah it's my
latest pennant right here
with baby on the mother brother
you know a cute one too what did that
run you
uh this dependent thirty thousand this
this we got [ __ ] fifty jesus they're
like eighty yeah you pay that all at
once yeah just shout out ralph yeah wow
that's a lot of money to just you know
how like when he was young
you would spend a lot of money on some
[ __ ] when you were leaving paycheck to
paycheck and it would hurt your stomach
and you'd be like you might buy like a
new car stereo or some sneakers and then
when you get in your car you're like
[ __ ] i still felt like that though i'm
cleaning it with money but i had to do
it though that's my little brother like
yeah 80s a lot yeah what's the most
expensive piece of jewelry you got
uh
probably yup probably this will get
the 50 the 50k guy yeah yeah
a [ __ ] around [ __ ]
do they do you feel cause you know what
i see a lot with uh jewelers and rappers
a lot of times man jewelers be taking
advantage of young rappers i see it all
the time too but you got certain that
that like to lock in like they'll throw
a promo or do promo for me i thought
right you got to work that angle like
look you got certain jewels that finesse
too they're like that's why when you get
though you got to get our own certified
something they told me to do but
you just got to make sure you got the
right diamonds because they'll miss like
s size and [ __ ] all up in your [ __ ]
they'll give you um flawed diamonds
that have that have been like filled
they'll give you the lab diamonds or
they'll give you like those super low
grade [ __ ] up
cloudy boys
as little dirk was saying today i
thought dirk was talking about that what
do you think about um not not the
specific situation but you know you've
obviously had some public disputes
when it comes to other artists yeah did
you see cowboy uh go at the baby today
because of uh the baby's decision to do
a project with nba young boy did you see
that
i see it but i saw it was what i heard
so
i guess the thing is is like a lot of
people are mad not a lot of people a few
people are mad at the baby for doing a
project with nba young boy
because nba young boy obviously has
problems with otf and all those guys and
the baby's like i'm i
i'm i mean i'm kind of an innocent
bystander in this thing i'm gonna work
with who i'm gonna work with i'm gonna
get money if just because i'm working
with him don't mean i ain't [ __ ] with
y'all like how do you feel about
something like that like if if someone
works with
let's say somebody does a whole project
with young and ace yeah do you
automatically see them as is [ __ ] them
or is it like
dog because
you don't got nothing to do with
jacksonville
stuff that's going on in the jazz bear
not unless you like dissing like no
there's no dissident involved it's just
it's just a collab on money like all
right do you do you like you ain't got
nothing to do with nothing that's why
the industry's weird right now bro they
making everybody piss but
it's super weird and it's not um
it's just not healthy yeah like yo
like at the end of the day like young
boy and the baby are both superstars
they want to do a project together like
doesn't mean like like you said now if
they're
if if there's some dissing going on on
that [ __ ] i totally get it yeah but i
feel like it's an opportunity for
a lot of people
to
i guess make the shade room
because they want to put a two cents in
they know if they say something they're
gonna get on academics yeah and it's
like bro like this [ __ ] is so
unnecessary it's kind of crazy
in general it's a little crazy yo we
gotta take a break in the interview real
quick tell you about our folks at my
bookie man this is my favorite time of
the year to gamble i love gambling on
sports and if you've been thinking about
putting your toe into the pool come and
join me at my bookie okay right now
we're doing a promotion and my bookie is
crazy when you sign up for a new account
and you make your first deposit they
will match that deposit up to a thousand
dollars it is march madness the ncaa
tournament is here the brackets is
getting filled out what i need y'all to
do also is go on to my bookie when you
sign up they got their my bracket
promotion going on it's pretty crazy so
essentially you sign up for my bracket
first place grand prize winner gets a
bitcoin a whole bitcoin second place get
some crazy ass nft that's worth a [ __ ]
ton of money i don't know [ __ ] about
nfts third place hundred thousand
dollars in cash and prizes so what are
you doing go to my bookie right now man
get in on some of this march madness
some of this nba action i wonder what
the odds were on tom brady coming back
from retirement sheesh
mybookie.ag use that promo code bootleg
b-o-o-t-l-e-g one word when you sign up
and your first deposit will be matched
up to a thousand dollars in free money
let's get back to the interview i
thought this would be the biggest like
how two pocket biggest [ __ ] was
i think that's the biggest like
b for whatever you want to call it
that's going on right now though cause
you got every like everybody responding
everybody making songs everybody putting
their two cents in
everybody picking sides is black balling
you talking about the dirk uh the young
boy man there's so much going on like
people died
died and yeah there's just a lot of
going on that [ __ ] like this dude what
confuses me
is that
they're not from the same city they're
not from the same hood
uh it feels like actual rat beef like
it's like what are y'all really beefing
about is it about like you know what i'm
saying as opposed to like well somebody
died no it's over no no no now but even
then it's like quando rondo and king
vaughn are from
a three and a half hour flight away from
each other four hours like what the [ __ ]
is like going on where like
[ __ ] really get to the point
where
it's it gets so disrespectful
blood gets shed
and
y'all ain't even from the same area this
is y'all wouldn't even know who each
other were from work for rap music yeah
like that's to me the [ __ ] that really
be i'll be seeing some of this [ __ ] to
be like
like i'm i'm not the biggest young boy
fan uh i mean i i like some of his [ __ ]
but i'm not like i don't like his antics
and sometimes
i feel like um
there's just so much unnecessary
negative energy bro and
you know i think that's why when you and
i talked last time you were here
it was like dope to see you kind of
opening your minds and not being uh
so many people i think when i told them
i was talking to you that was the first
thing they associated you with yeah was
that negative [ __ ]
and you know to talk to you i mean what
it's been like seven or eight months
later to see you in a better space it's
good it's good to see man
even with uh
i can do what i did the interview act he
probably thought i was a [ __ ] up
person he got to meet me he was like you
really you cool right no i ain't expect
that for you like it just you got to
meet somebody and like feel they vibe
you don't know what to judge a person
because no i'm saying you get a
different vibe when you're on somebody
while you're really you're a good hearty
dude he got a good soul you know what
i'm saying you can feel people energy
that's real how how would you gauge
academic synergy
that cool is there
alright
i'd expect her to be like how he was
like personal person like he was really
how you would give me advice on
i want to see you alive i want to see
you do this i want you to he was doing
the same thing and i respect that
because you ain't just talking about
this all to be if you want to see me
make it as far as like as a man you know
what i'm saying you want to see me grow
you understand
i respect
yeah i like acts come up story i think
that
he does
perpetuate some of the
the negative [ __ ] like it's kind of his
it's kind of his business i guess if
he's not going to do it someone else is
going to do it yeah say cheese tv is
going to pose everyone's going to but
that's all that's this is the industry
it's their job yeah that's some real
[ __ ] that's their job it's like yo like
you can't get mad at
this person and not get mad at the 38
other websites and blogs that do the
same [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah so many people do the same [ __ ]
they don't get the amount of negative
energy that academics gets i think it's
i think it's the
what you we saw him every day on
everyday struggle yeah and we put a face
to the blog and it was like oh no no no
we know who he is now yeah that's
exactly what it was because you never
saw that when he was doing this little
right warren chicago and all that you
never knew who he was did he ever do he
never did a war in jacksonville did he
because i know someone did because i've
seen him she really added to a lot of
them he did a lot of videos reacting to
it
do you ever go watch those youtube
videos because they got millions and
millions of views i think i saw like two
three of them
were pretty inaccurate
yeah majority of it but they really just
going off of what the next person said
uh what the news saying you know what
i'm saying
someone falls somewhere true but i just
look at it like oh blog [ __ ]
how are you in terms of just like making
sure like you're
staying out of the way making sure
you're staying off the radar
when it comes to just
keeping your business straight like you
know i feel like a lot of times
especially nowadays man rappers are big
targets when it comes to just
taxes law enforcement whatever it is
like y'all got a target on your back not
only in the streets not only when you're
going to the [ __ ] grocery store not
only all that but
on the other side of the fence too with
the legal [ __ ] like
um
there's [ __ ] hip-hop police divisions
you know what i'm saying like this is a
real thing that's going on like like
how how mindful of you that that's that
that's something to also make sure that
you're
out of the way of as well
sure
like i said it's the way you move and
you just can't be like just doing like
say of
i know
um how can i put this
i gotta i gotta pro i ain't gonna need
let's go tonight because i often
[Music]
don't implicate anything no i don't know
i just mean in terms of like like are
you like are you just making sure you're
on top of your [ __ ]
yeah
like if i'll be 12 with somebody we got
we got to be at the same place i'm gonna
make sure i'm not there i don't want
nothing to happen obviously and i ain't
trying to mess up the business and i
know the police watching so you know so
now i'm gonna just remove either remove
myself from the situation i just get it
straight get down
get what i'm saying i ain't gonna
indulge in the bush you know what i'm
saying have you ever been in a situation
where
you made the decision
to get up out of there because it had
you stuck around some [ __ ] might have
went down and you're like you know what
i got i got family to get home too
little time i got a date i got a day to
see you tomorrow plenty of times there's
been plenty of situations multiple
situations that takes a lot because
prior to [ __ ] with you and yeah like nah
he gotta leave yeah but we're gonna see
him you know what i'm saying yeah then
you can't get you can't get another life
this ain't gta or
a video game once you dead your dad bro
so you just gotta that's a mind thing
you know what i'm saying 100 and you've
seen enough deaths
close to you man to know that this [ __ ]
ain't nothing to play with exactly
you know take even take advantage of the
fact that you're still here and uh
you're you're winning what about um on
the label side have you because are you
still independent yeah i got a
distribution deal with create music
shout out to create they distribute a
bunch of people's [ __ ] yeah but that
you're fully that for people who don't
know
that's he's independent um
[Music]
what about signing is that something
that you've gotten close to doing or is
that something you can like you would
consider doing because i'm sure that
the labels have called
multiple layers um from gucci man
uh q seals from the time you once upon a
time
i don't remember epic atlanta i'll put
me with atlanta probably like last week
a couple days ago or something like that
a lot of labels though but
that made sense to me what was the
closest cause gucci i mean gucci's i
always say gucci's probably the greatest
hip-hop a r of all time
did you like how serious were you when
it came to maybe getting with with gucci
or qc i want to sign a goodie so bad bro
but it's just
not to put the prices out there i just
couldn't sign for a hundred thousand all
right that's not
a hundred thousand what's the deal yeah
hundred thousand and i'm like i got that
times [ __ ] in my bank account
you know what i'm saying all right and
jury i'm plus
and i'm like [ __ ] it was a respectful
decline yeah
but i still assigned something but it
just gotta make sense
a lot more sense or even if we do like
a collab or
feature or whatever one-off album or
something you know what i'm saying like
it just gotta make sense but as far as a
full-on artist deal with me signing to
you for a honey hell nah nah that's
crazy yeah no i would tell you don't
sign anywhere for less than a million
dollars because you're making
you're making my road to just some money
i'm saying you're making good money off
of off of what you're doing right now
yeah
and
you're you're owning everything you own
the master's
um but this one what the [ __ ] you see i
was dead broke
like and he tried to give me 150k
my face and i was like damn i'm just
saying just thinking like [ __ ]
[ __ ]
it went through and um i was talking to
the like people i was working with my
management but end up not like going all
the way through
so you almost did that one yeah i almost
i was close to doing it but then at the
end it was like nah wow yeah i mean it
takes a lot to uh
pass up on on monday like that i mean
and know yourself worth a lot of artists
i think that that whole entire
record industry is based on
big companies taking advantage
of starving artists and then nowadays
though
i don't know if it's just i'm pretty
sure everybody see it but it's like
every time i get on instagram i see
artists complaining about their label
like oh don't sign this meal young i
mean everybody and by the way we're
talking about atlantic in both cases so
it's probably better
i didn't know that but i'll just be
seeing that [ __ ] down there like every
[ __ ] other day that somebody
complaining about that label that's it's
scary bro no it's scary because once you
sign
you can't say i want to put this out
tomorrow
it's like nah we got to sign off on it
and then guess what
uh your budget is this you got to pay
this i mean it's a shitty loan is what
it is it's a high interest loan so like
if you would have taken that i don't
know the details of the deal but if you
would have taken that hundred thousand
from gucci
you would have probably had to have made
a million back off of that hundred for
you to start seeing money again exactly
so you would have made that hundred last
for a while and that's that's the
advanced game and most most big artists
that we're talking about you talking
about meek mill
yg's been very vocal about what's
alfredo being say something about def
jam right so what though
the reason why these guys are so mad is
because
every time they drop an album they get
an advance check
and that's the last money they see from
that album because they make it so hard
for you to recoup
that
million dollars every time you turn in
your album
that you got to make that stretch or you
got to get them that show money or you
got to get that endorsement money or you
got to get your features right because
unless your album
is
inc like rotty rich diamond you know
like some [ __ ] like that you're probably
never going to see any money off that
album
and so that's why you see all these huge
artists saying [ __ ] the labels but but
at the same time they sign those deals
and they and they gladly pick up that
advance check when they turn that album
in
what they could do is say
keep the advance take the album and i
just want to get paid my monthly
royalties off the album yeah
exactly
it's the short it's it's the long play
not the short night you know what i'm
saying yeah so when artists get angry
and uh
i don't feel bad because i'm like yo you
you son like
some of these dudes are grown-ass man
y'all feel bad but some artists really
don't know i feel like if you were young
and you were super vulnerable and you
got signed that way that's one thing but
some of the artists we're talking about
in the game they know have resigned many
times and it's like you know this [ __ ]
so like you you know what you signed up
for like you signed the [ __ ]
paperwork you got the best lawyers in
the [ __ ] music industry like they
get something yeah that was a problem
too i ain't gonna have lawyers like that
you gotta have a lot of fun to pay so
i'm like i need to play with myself and
don't let them be like yo we know a good
lawyer you gotta look yeah because then
they're gonna [ __ ] you
get your own lawyer
and yeah not keep running up the bag
independently when the right situation
crosses your table you'll know bro keep
ownership on your masters
don't sign no [ __ ]
whole ass split because these fools will
definitely try to get you to take
seven percent of your music
they want to take your catalog they
wanna and they're like oh by the way
that independent catalog at create we'd
like to bring it over here to atlantic
and we wanna own it yeah would you ever
sign like somewhere like an empire
because empire is a distro situation
i think i own they sent me like a little
distribution deal or something like that
to start off but
if it made sense yeah it just gotta make
sense to me but i can't just be out here
just you know what i'm saying if i bring
i i know what i bring to the table i
know what my numbers do of course apple
the spotify to youtube i know what i do
so it for me to just give up some of my
royalties and my you know some masters
and this and that it got to make a lot
of sense for me yo we gotta stop the
interview real quick shout out to our
presenting sponsor odd socks baby hey
man listen all i keep on my ass is odd
socks draws all i keep on my feet are
socks you know why because they're the
most comfortable socks in the world and
i'm not just saying this because they
promote the podcast i'm telling you the
socks are crazy uh they got all the
licenses look they got halloween socks
they have back to the future socks
they got [ __ ] twizzler socks
old dirty bastard socks r.i.p to odb
alright they also got their draws if you
want to wear some underwear with pizza
on them whatever you need but my
favorite are the odd socks basics baby
these are just the plain boys these to
me are the most comfortable socks in the
world all right
so trust me when i say go to
oddssoxofficial.com
thank me later when you go to check out
find the most comfortable socks in the
world
get some wwe socks too i just saw a
sneak peek of the new wwe line and
they're [ __ ] insane
in [ __ ] sane
uh go to oddssocksofficial.com
use the promo code bootleg kev that's
one word together bootleg kev
we should talk to them about shortening
that bootleg cab is the promo code you
will get 20 off at checkout one more
time go to oddssocksofficial.com save 20
off using that promo code bootleg cab
let's get back to the interview all
right
not to dive into your the uh stereotype
of who people think you are
having a lot of beef dealing with a lot
of ops
currently
vladimir putin is invading ukraine yeah
you know have you you've been paying
attention yeah gas prices are [ __ ] up
right now [ __ ] though i just i just saw
850 in [ __ ] west hollywood i i was i
almost threw up in my mouth
it cost me 160 to fill up my suv yeah
terrible uh
you're the president of the united
states how you handling putin if who if
julio julio is the president
how are you handling this [ __ ]
we need trump back in that [ __ ]
real [ __ ] trump i would have did what i
had to do in war
did what it is you can't just you can't
it's basically like extortion you can't
just distort people because you feel
like a vulnerable or you want to take
back over what they got going on you
want them back under your control so i
feel like it's like you praying on
on a week you know what i'm saying but i
feel like he's gonna go to jail for war
crimes i talked about that i saw
something like that
so if it were up to you you would have
never have gotten rid of trump yeah i
would have killed trump trump was with
all the trump gangster
he was with all the [ __ ] yeah i
would have kept trump in the office for
sure
and a lot of people a lot of people had
that ppp and that edd off of trump
yeah what a cat trouble officer
did you
are you able to vote
are you
i don't know i don't know what your
criminal history is i don't know
i got my gun license i would have by the
way first of all in florida uh in
florida you could be a felon and vote i
know you're not a felon but i think
florida is one of the only states that
you could do that well i don't even know
but i ain't no felon though but you i
mean yeah no that's dope do you do you
vote
no i don't think i voted i don't think i
ever voted in my life i can imagine you
at a just standing in line
on super tuesday night though
waiting to cast your trump ballot yeah
if trump reruns would you go vote for
trump
if i had a time to do it if you had the
time you'd have to have the time yeah
what was your favorite part about
the trump presidency i guess
she
he pardoned lil wayne [ __ ]
and kodak black yeah koda
did he pardon anyone oh he's he he did
save asap rocky from uh what country
sweden i thought he'll put the free joe
exotic damn
i saw something
hey i swear i thought the same [ __ ] they
said the people was waiting outside his
family was waiting outside for him and
all right they did not park if he would
have free man can you imagine the inner
the how ill joe exotic's instagram would
be right now if he was out lit i might
have been lit i know that [ __ ] was in
oklahoma
but if that ain't the most florida-ass
[ __ ] i ever seen in my life that show i
know i lived in florida so i can speak
on it what show
[ __ ] uh
tiger king oh yeah i'm tripping that
[ __ ] happened in oklahoma but it is that
is some florida joe exotic is some
florida ass [ __ ]
like middle of florida like you've
you've you've done these shows
yo florida is such a weird
it's like its own country yeah because
if you get into certain pockets of
florida it is
backwoods redneck hillbilly ass [ __ ]
it's crazy bro yeah like key west and
pensacola
yeah
up near alabama yeah you'll get [ __ ]
up right i went to jail one time right
through them
skirts and [ __ ] like that yes like man
florida's his own thing and then there's
miami miami's like the only [ __ ] that's
like miami too yeah they like they own
this [ __ ] and it's a bunch of like rich
retired [ __ ] in the south and
then yeah yeah florida's a wild place
man
jacksonville they always call it
jacksonville
uh south atlanta
i don't know i don't know or south
georgia south georgia south georgia
because it's it's so close to georgia oh
yeah yeah you're right we like probably
like i went 30 for savannah
so yeah it's close to georgia but i feel
like we we
we got the number one murderer right now
we got our look on the style of music it
just like we we got the face of florida
right now i want to cut the music in
what's really going on in florida
um
i feel like
i'm i i would i listen drake always taps
in with like the young
i guess wave of what's going on that's
my favorite rapper too shout out
has drake tapped in with like you at all
no he liked one of my posts though that
means he's watching yeah he like one of
my favorites he's into what you're doing
yeah shout out to it yeah i wouldn't be
surprised like i feel like i feel like
drake sometimes will just pick a
up-and-coming artist and be like you
know what and that's why i raw him let
me change your life real quick yeah like
black boy jb yeah you know what i'm
saying like [ __ ] like so many artists
like that i love who's to do the same
thing too who's he too but but nothing's
like drake yeah drake when drake's
now when drake is on a record it's over
yeah though it changes it changes the
game automatically gold platinum
it's like oh it's automatically a single
is automatically getting played
everywhere so drake sure you're you're
you're number one top of the top right
who's who who fills out the rest of your
top five nobody's drake drake times five
straight times five what's your favorite
drake album
oh
probably take care oh do i want to say
that
oh yeah that's what it is i think take
care is his best album
my favorite though is nothing was the
same
yeah
even though take care is better yeah i
ain't gonna count
with that um what's wrong with that all
i hear is fireworks
fireworks is gonna take care right but
that'll take good you're more of a drake
fan than me i think it's a cook beats
that was my favorite i used to rap out
that instrumental like back to back
though when i was little
shout out to drizzy yeah that [ __ ] was
so hard again that when i first
discovered the weekend i ain't no i
thought the weekend oh he was on crew
love yeah yeah that one out first yeah
yeah that's crazy a long time 2012. that
was two yeah that was 10 years ago yeah
that was a long long
damn that's 10 years ago 2012 man we
getting old as [ __ ] oh gang that [ __ ]
made me think i'm 23.
i just saw some there was some [ __ ] that
just uh there was a 15 year anniversary
for some album and i was like [ __ ] i
remember when that [ __ ] came out
oh my god damn i'm getting up there
what are you doing in your spare time
like just to pass the time what are your
hobbies you play video games yeah i like
call of duty 2k
i saw you [ __ ] with um what's the
kid's name who's on twitch aiden ross oh
yeah
oh yeah and i got a pc too i'll be on
gta online on the pc [ __ ] and t
grizzlies i'm on the world and [ __ ]
should you be playing a t grizzlies
thing yeah that's your heart like i love
that [ __ ] do you do is it's called role
playing right yeah role play i gotta
twitch and all but i ain't been on it
lately but yeah i got a twitch too so
when you do role playing on a video game
walk me through this because i played
gta but i've only played the story mode
i've never played online
real life how you would play in real
life like i said if you want to wake up
and be a doctor today you gonna wake up
go do your work no i'm saying clock in
clock guy go check on the medicine it's
like basically like real life but you
only you're on the headset talking yeah
you gotta really be into it though cause
i saw uh they like set t grizzly up and
robbed them yeah in the game and i was
like real life i'm like wait why is this
going viral it's grand theft auto this
is what happens
that's crazy they got chick-fil-a burger
king all typing [ __ ] on that bit that's
it hard wow it's hard t grizzly's
getting a bag off that [ __ ]
yeah you got to go crazy on twitch
because there's money especially if
you're [ __ ] with aidan ross
he's kind of like the um the drake of
twitch
or no what's the other guy's name ninja
no ninja the fortnight guy but but
ninjas ninja's rich but
ayden is the goat bro hit like he had a
run and i ain't he had every artist in
his house
doing interviews on the game can we be
honest yeah it was very very
surprising to me that no one robbed him
because everything's cool
everyone was at his house and you know
entourages are there
hey it's just cool as yeah bro i promise
you get around here blind down you're
cool how did you guys link up because
that was such a random thing to see uh
he dissed my people
like my dad home boys but we talked
about it and i got an understanding like
any mean no harm or not like that so
was it him uh like singing along to that
song he was saying along but he didn't
mean no harm he knew what was going on
but he facetimed me we talked it up and
then i ended up coming to l.a
he would like pull up on me and i pulled
up to his house he had so many security
guards and all the type of [ __ ]
i ain't gonna do [ __ ] to you bro then we
did the online stream and we talked
about it is that kind of hard like um
when you know that like
there are people who sing along to that
record not knowing what the [ __ ] they're
singing along to
yeah
i don't know i'm tripping it's not hard
to just
i know you this is not your lifestyle so
i can understand you just vibing to them
you like most people don't think the way
you think yeah thank god you think that
way because most people are very
irrational when they're like
like you said like you know we were
talking earlier about the [ __ ] with the
with the baby and nba youngblood it's
like why are people so worked up over
this dude he ain't got [ __ ] to do
without like this whole situation like
but yeah and i think that's that's a
good thing man uh what's so you say
you're dropping two mixtapes and an
album yeah that's that's kind of what my
plan is gonna be if not album for sure
the two mistakes two mixtapes maybe an
album and shout out quavo he gave him a
name for my mixtape what's the name i
ain't gonna i ain't gonna draw the name
yet quavo gave you the name though yeah
like two three days ago in the club
i like that shout out quick quail was a
good guy the migos are the i mean i
think
all three of them are super nice dudes
yeah i didn't even know they knew
nothing about my music or nothing bro
yeah
i just saw this video offset performing
ric flair drip in a fur at the club did
you see that video cook and he was like
i was like bro i saw that i was like
dude i was like this [ __ ] is a
superstar
i was like
harry flynn paige presents stage
presence like shout out to offset man
[ __ ] who if you could um pick any artist
that's like more realistic obviously you
would do a whole album with drake so
just just let's let's get rid of drake
as an answer if you could do a collab
album with anyone who would it be
uh
pilot polo g
that would be fire apology
uh
i don't think i can rap
see i'm like weird i do something like
billy ellis or some [ __ ] like that
really eyelash yeah some [ __ ] like that
do you listen to her music a couple of
songs and it's a um
so i'll be saying a name hope i do
something
billy eilish hope apology yeah
i wouldn't take you for a billy eilish
listener i go i could make like real
melodic type music though i really like
heart bro
type [ __ ] though like
i could tap into that there it is well
listen i appreciate you pulling up we're
going to drop another freestyle too so
go check that video out
uh new mixtapes coming new music come in
and anything else you want to plug
before we get up out of here nah just
tune in two tapes on the way driving
soon april boning